こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
みなさん
夏ですね
泳げますか？
ぼく
泳げないんです
プールとか海は
すごい、行きたい行きたいマンなんですけど
けして、泳ぐことができないという
いわゆる、かなづちまでとはいかないですけど
そこそこ泳げない
犬かきしかできない系男子です
夏までに
なんとかこう
少しでも泳げるようになりたいなと
思いまして
泳げないって永遠の悩みなんですよ～～～～～～
学校とかそういう機会がないと
そもそも、練習する機会とかもないし
俺は、これをどうしようと思った時に
ひらめきました
はい、こちら
40ｍまで遠隔操作ができて
陸・水・氷の3つのシーンを走行
どこでも走れるみたいなもんすね
ほんとに、水でも走れるようなラジコンなんですけど
結局、人間っていうのはね
追い込まれたときに
真の力が発揮されるんですよ
なので
僕は、ちんたらちんたら
泳ぐ練習してる暇ないんで
これを使って、半強制的に
泳げるようになる方法を僕が考えたのでやってみたいと思います
あけます
ほ～～
あ、でた
なんかかわいいね～
コントローラーはこれでつきました
これ今オンでしょ
動くの？
おおおお～
おおお～
おおおおおお～～
結構、スピードは出そうですね
あ、すごい　すごい　すごい
ぜんぜん行ける
すごい電池食いそうだな
取り合えず外に行ってきます
海まで来ました
オンになりました、動かしてみます
え、結構緊張するんだけど
やばい、きたきたきた
ぼこぼこすごいんだけど
え、いくよいくよ
おおおおおおおお～
お～行けるイケル
はい、というわけで
とりあえず動くというのはわかりました
こっから、僕が強制的に
泳げるようになるために
充電があと10分ぐらいもつんで
10分間逃げ切ったら
僕の勝ち
では、まいる
いきます
え
うそじゃん
無理だよ～泳げないもん
え、ひ～
わ～～
ホント大丈夫、俺死なないよね？
大丈夫っすよ
ね～ぬるぬるした～～
わ～～～～～
普通に汚いんだよな
シンプルにね
シンプルに汚い
やるか
始めますか？
よしこ～い
わ、あぶね～
あ、あ、くっそ～
死んだ？
ハハハハハ
とどめだ
わ～～～
ハハハハハ
ははは
音痴が歌う
？